with Leonardo DiCaprio getting another
Oscar nomination I felt it would be good
to go check this video out I have made
the reasoning for watching this make
sense
I'm Greg I'm Kyle fan theory TV go check
out his reaction channel got a whole lot
of people reacting a whole bunch of
shows over there it's quite the
community guys are gonna watching this
channel vj4
rawr - and so does on that movie section
on youtubes training page interesting
it's called Titanic - Jack's back Jack's
back reboot 2020 movie trailer parody
10k dislikes on this and I bet some
people I thought this was a real trailer
[Music]
grammar
[Music]
[Laughter]
mr. the thing remit is equal whatever
Kriegel
a home from always I called I've seen
everybody
hey good its place
[Laughter]
is too funny
oh my god this is the theme song that we
watch what's Tourette's which is a show
theory TV oh god I love I love this
concept there was dragging his life
through there was a time where this
might have been possible Hollywood I
think absolutely would have greenlit it
just the image of him in the ice Oh
perfect that is such a perfect image how
could you not love that but I loved the
concept that they did with this to make
it some weird science fiction
psychological thriller pulling from all
the images based on a true actual
occurrence taking images from like
shutter island' departed inception what
is it called the reader or Kate Winslet
at all yeah I think 15 year old kid or
something like that yeah the amount of
splicing they did I thought this was
edited really well because they just
have to make it great enough mm-hmm
where it's just believable enough yeah
but it's mainly about being funny yeah
you know like there are those fanfiction
trailers that you'll see that I've seen
for like DC or marvel movie crossovers
I'm like that yeah you want to make
those look as realistic as possible
this whole goal was to make you laugh
and I think they greatly succeeded I
think she was waiting for watching sheer
Depression years but then also like the
amount of brain trauma and injuries that
have occurred from being frozen in the
ice like dealing with that concept this
is this is a perfect video seriously
thank you thank you that's all I got to
say thank thank you
thank you I'm gonna be I'm gonna be
showing this to a lot of people this is
one of those videos I'm gonna showed it
to many people from here on out
hopefully this pin comment says there's
a 1 here Titanic to never let go that's
our sequel and Titanic to the return of
Jack the feel-good sequel oh so like
similar concept but different images and
stuff yeah osode what did you see one of
the ones from like you Wei Wei long time
ago but this looks like a much more
cleaned up updated version of whatever I
saw yeah and then they added in
different clips that didn't exist when I
got like this supports the beginning of
YouTube it's like it's pretty old this
is so well edited when it gets to the
point where they take the shutter
island' moment i love the idea of jack
changing his style his hair cut he just
keeps change like having different
haircuts does he have another could have
pulled some footage off of I'm drying
major blinks was the one where Caitlin's
at Emory revolutionary that's what I was
trying to yeah yeah yeah revolutionary
road but then again it would have made
sense because didn't they use like one
these clip it in I don't think they use
any footage of them together yeah
because we're not work for the story guy
think about the story here I think this
makes sense that it flows you know guys
if you haven't done this already please
subscribe to VJ for our two and then
also Billy Krammer gosh I got his
channel that sounds great I love when
people collab together subscribe to the
real rejects if you so desire check out
Kyle's channel fan theory TV and I'd
like to end this with a patron of the
day shout out to a man named Luke
Anderson Luke recently got back to me
spent a whole year making the same joke
about his card being on file and now
once hearing a peep from him and his
pledge just stayed through all through
2019 finally got back to me
I thought he was frozen in ice himself
see what I did there Luke I tied it back
in to the whole Jack bean
frozen it you get it I could have had a
better punchline but then I got
distracted by the fact of how great I
did at tying it back it look I hope you
have a better 2020 and I hope that we
can continue to chat some more knowing
what there's some rough things but hey
now that your unthawed go out there and
you know a little bit good let's say
something positive Kyle you used his
name the last time we did a reaction
together X almost 1 year ago
[Laughter]